[Music]
uh my name is will i'm one of the
admission officers here at the stanford
graduate school of business
we're going to be talking about
activities work history and the resume
um where does this all come from so
one of the big things that we care about
a lot this is something that has been
really near and dear to my heart working
with dean moss and the rest of our team
is how can we make sure as many people
have access information
um and the ability to really understand
this admission process knowing that
business school admissions and the
questions we ask can often feel just
like a different world from other types
of applications if you're from a country
that uses like test scores as a primary
way of figuring out what school you go
to
the holistic review process can be very
different and the types of questions we
ask are different so how can we really
democratize access to that um wherever
in the world you're from whatever
resources you have or may not have
access to um so that's where these all
come from
so
this year's workshops actually build on
last year's workshops so
my teammates if you could please pop in
the links to some of the different
workshops we had before so there's
navigating the application what matters
most an essay workshop and then there's
three on sharing your story
what does the story mean in business
school admissions
how do you start it like what parts
things should you consider
how do you communicate that in the
written form and then how do you
communicate that in the verbal form so
like networking and interviews
so the that series of uh workshops super
interactive there's places for you to
pause do some writing and thinking along
and go at your own pace
this year sessions are building on that
so it's going to be a little bit more of
me talking
so i apologize for that it's not as
interactive but we did get some feedback
that um you would love to know more
about the process how do we think about
it at the gsb and so really trying to
embed that within here
so take this as it goes it's a process
there's going to be multiple sessions
that we're holding on different topics
and like i mentioned this builds on what
already exists so if you already want to
jump in there
get going get your hands dirty get your
feet wet all of that is available on our
youtube channel
the goal
is really not to tell you what to do or
what you should put in the application
but give you the tools to a
figure out hey here's who i am and b how
can i share this with them and i'm using
them kind of broadly because hopefully
some of the things we talk about will be
helpful regardless of what school you
might be interested in maybe you're not
even thinking about going to business
school at all maybe there's stuff that
you're taking away for the job search or
application to a different kind of grad
program
um and really
helping find that power and value
and pride and confidence
in where your journey is going to take
you so
preface there is a lot of advice out
there some of it's good some of it's bad
um
maybe not bad but maybe some of it's
less applicable to you as an individual
throw whatever you hear in here today it
within there right
this is not a golden rule for how you
need to do anything um these are just
hey different ways to think about stuff
here are different pieces of advice
incorporate ones that feel right for you
and then you know save those other
pieces in your back pocket know they're
out there but you do not need to listen
to anybody listen to yourself that is
the goal
and for the things that i'm talking
about today i'm going to be talking
about them specifically through the lens
of the gsb mba admissions process so i
will not be talking about the msx
admissions process they have their own
info session so definitely recommend
checking that out
but for things like resume
you are definitely going to have coaches
and support from the career management
center recommendations for if you're
thinking about pivoting advancing who
your audience might be
today your audience is going to be the
mba admissions office so how can we help
you
understand the way we think about things
and what are stuff that
i've seen my team has seen so that we
can share you know best practices and or
opportunities to make sure you're
putting again yourself in the best light
okay
strategy
so this is the framework that we're
using i kind of made it up
so i don't know if it's actually a
framework but we're going to be calling
it reframe and reclaim
the goal is for us to think about common
questions
and instead of like
waiting and like giving somebody else
the power over them how can we ask those
questions in different ways so that you
have ownership and you have power over
what comes next so what do i mean
let's use this an example what's the
biggest mistake you see
in the application when it comes to
resumes work history activities i have a
feeling if
you're not already asking this you might
have seen it before or you might be
curious so we're just gonna open with it
so let's turn this on its head let's
reframe that to what are some of the
biggest opportunities that you see right
and this is where i get really excited
opportunity because all of you are going
to be using the application differently
and that's exciting so
what are we going to do uh we're going
to give a million dollar question
some of you might have this question in
mind already y'all might be thinking
about it it might seem familiar we're
going to tackle that one head on
talk about
these sections what does it mean within
the context of our application
evaluation process
then we'll also talk about things like
what should i share how do i share it in
a way that's going to be most effective
and also i'll try my best to save some
time at the end for live q a for
anything that we haven't covered over
the course of this session i do have
sections that are lightning round
frequently asked questions so hopefully
you'll also be able to knock some of
those out along the way
so
here we go
i don't know how many of you might have
thought this asked it
or have seen other people ask it in a
webinar for example
i am a blank blank blank
can i get in
and i get this question a lot
let's reframe and reclaim so
we need to know about the foundations of
the gsb admissions process
the holistic review process so here's
the
dictionary definition but in admissions
and in our office we think about it as
taking everything that you submit to get
an understanding of who you are right
the way you think
the things that you do
who's this individual that's going to
show up on our campus in our classroom
and our community so we're going to be
taking a look at everything you submit
testing transcripts all of that to get a
sense of who you are
so practically what does that mean
there's no formulas there's no equations
so if you start a question with this how
much do you weigh
already reframe that right because we
don't we don't weigh there is no plus or
minus scale right we're looking at
everything together
we don't have benchmarks cutoffs or
minimums or quotas so often we get the
question how many people do you take
from my blank
that is not a question that we ask
ourselves on the admission side we are
looking for talent
and leadership regardless of what
where you're coming from more on that in
a second
no one part of the application is more
or less important than the other and
context matters
and so today we're really gonna be these
two pieces are gonna shine really
brightly and then also the no part of
the application you're out you're gonna
see why you know one part is not more or
less important but they can all work
together to help us understand you so
we're gonna unpack each one of these
with a little bit more detail
so what does that mean when it comes to
that million dollar question
so let's take an example so we're just
going to put some meat on these bones i
am a let's say nigerian go ahead super
eagles um engineer um with you know
testing and gpa
these are not criteria that we are
necessarily looking for in and of
themselves right
so
what are they we're thinking about
background industry academic
you know academic history
these are all pieces of context that
help inform
right your achievements
so
let's say if you are an engineer in
nigeria the opportunities the job
trajectory the things that are around
you are probably going to look very very
different than maybe a consultant in
japan
right and so helping us understand where
in the world and where in your life
you're coming from
that helps us understand okay
how are these leadership competencies
emerging what does this mean in the
context of your life
so let's reframe this to
how do my experiences as blank blank
blank or the intersection of some of
these different identities right that
concept of intersectionality
how do those shape who i am
and inform my
accomplishments this is one of those
foundational questions that throughout
this process as you're thinking about
there's a lot about metacognition right
it's not just what you do but and how
you think but how do you think about how
you think which is also going to be a
really great tool
as you're a leader in different settings
right
what happened in that situation why did
i act that way is there something else i
could have done or i might be able to do
in the future either to amend that
situation or to be more effective
you're already in that situation now
with the application so i want you to
start practicing that
why does this matter so what we're
looking for in the application
last year and for those so in case you
started this process before maybe you're
reapplying um you might have seen these
phrases they've evolved to this and this
year we're really trying to be even more
upfront about what we're looking for and
notice they're still really big buckets
how do you think
how do you lead and how do you see the
world
these are all again background agnostic
industry agnostic
academic history
you know all of those things
they show up in different ways for
different people
and so that also means the way that
you're going to be using the application
is going to be different across the
board and that comes back to that
preface and my kind of grain of salt
advice what work for one person may or
may not work for you and that's okay so
let's figure out different types of
advice to figure out which ones might
work for you
so
application composed of multiple parts
go ahead and jump on our website right
now if you want even if you're not
thinking about applying for another few
years you can start an application and
click through
that's going to be something i recommend
later on again as a best practice so i
want to call it out nice and early
but rather than thinking about each one
of these pieces in
in a in a silo
we're thinking about these working
together to paint the picture of who you
are and yeah there's like gaps and stuff
in the image by necessity you know like
you are a three-dimensional
multi-faceted human
that we're trying to interpret through
like the 2d uh application
but help us get this picture of who you
are and these pieces can work together
to do that and today we're going to be
focused on these three sections right
optional responses
activities and work history and resume
so
let's go ahead and start with some
frequently asked questions and we're
going to play the game reframe and
replay
so here's one
what if i don't have any formal work
experience maybe you are a college
senior or maybe you just started work
one or two years in
um what if i have many years of
experience it's the same question kind
of just from a different direction right
for us
it's not about how many years you've
worked but given how many years or how
many years you have it right where
wherever in your life you are
what have you done how have you done it
how have you made an impact and where
those footprints you've left behind
because you could do that whether you've
worked one year or 50 years what does
that look like for you
what if i don't have many outside
activities
how do you spend your time
right because we totally understand
there's some
industries or jobs maybe you're an
entrepreneur where you're constantly
working so you don't have time for
outside maybe there is
work-life balance and you really just
really want to preserve that personal
time that's okay
maybe there's family obligations
help us understand what you do outside
of the work setting
you'd be surprised at how many different
places in your life you might be
demonstrating leadership competencies
and skills
in quote-unquote non-professional spaces
right you might be helping your family
through um emergencies grit resilience
leadership communication
conflict resolution maybe right so
take that moment and appreciate all of
the things you're doing in life
and weirdly for a business school
application sometimes those are the
moments that help shed the most light on
who you are
okay how do i demonstrate that i'm
qualified for blank this is a question i
often get and for the gsb specifically
you don't have to convince me you don't
have to convince me of how employable or
how viable your dream is for what you
want to do beyond business school
we firmly believe if you get into the
gsb
um we will have the support systems if
you're willing to put in the work we can
make magic happen together right so it's
less about convincing us
have a goal have a dream have something
that you care about
for us it's about past behavior as a key
indicator for how you might behave in
the future so for the things that you've
done how have you done them what was
that impact because hey these might be
some of the skills that you're going to
be exhibiting again in the future so
that retrospective look that
introspection uh the reflection
definitely key in the gsp application
process
and then how optional is optional
here's a question i want you to ask
yourself
optional totally optional whether or not
to use them is
will this space
help me share my story effectively and
so
we're gonna get to some ways to impact
that further so
already getting there so jumping ahead
ways to prepare
for what you might share
and if you guessed whatever you want
that might be fair and thank you i am
ready to receive my pulitzer now so um
moving on to that reflection piece so
this is a non-exhaustive list of things
that you might be able to think back on
i know for myself growing up reflection
was not
something that was kind of
talked about it like my family
culturally it was keep your head down do
your work that's how you're gonna get
ahead in life
as i've grown up and as i've moved into
different spaces personally
professionally socially
there are different ways of approaching
this and so
not i want to do more than just say
reflect
but where can we start because i know i
never would have known where to start if
you told me this even ten years ago five
years ago so hopefully these can be some
starting points for you um wherever in
the world wherever whatever context
you're at
to begin this this kind of iterative
process so what's your path
another question that i often get is i
don't have a linear path i've tried
different things so what i want you to
think about is how might those chapters
look what happened in them and more
importantly what about those transition
zones between chapters those pivot
points
why did they happen what informed them
who are you now because of them
and i think as you start to draw those
lines and connections between kind of
forward motions you turn the ups and
downs you're going to get a better sense
of who you are
not just because of the well
very much because of them right not
every story is a linear
but every story has value and purpose so
really start to unpack that for you
for yourself
and then as we think about the
milestones themselves these are some of
the anecdotes that you're probably going
to be sharing in your application right
so
often we get caught up in these without
taking the time to notice what that ebb
and flow of your path is but we really
also want you to think about the
milestones what are things that you're
proud of um
and one that i'm going to talk about a
little bit more on that next slide is
impact it's a very charged word there's
a lot of ways to interpret it
so i want us to break that down
because each and every one of you
already is having an impact right and
the challenge is being able to step
outside and look at it from different
perspectives to honor that which can be
very hard as an individual
so if you want to take a screenshot now
is the time to get some of these
questions and you can take that photo in
five four three two and go ahead and
take that snapshot
all right so moving on
let's talk about those milestones a
little bit more
so what is meaningful for you
and i mean this very broadly there are
different ways to interpret this maybe
it's the action or the outcomes that
were meaningful for you
think about two or three anecdotes in
your life personal professional
things that you're proud of remember
that question from the previous slide
why were they meaningful for you what
were some of the actions that surrounded
them
you might have heard of the star kind of
framework situation task action result
often used for interviews that can also
be a really great starting point for
what how you think about these anecdotes
in your life
two other pieces that i want you to to
explore and unpack with are context
so
what are some of the situations and
circumstances
around kind of the situation like is it
a challenge that your company has been
facing for a really long time
is this a large workplace that you know
you often don't get much visibility up
or down some of these additional
contextual pieces can often be helpful
for us to understand
oh okay maybe there is a greater
distance traveled here maybe you are
working within kind of broader like um
kind of headwinds what does that mean
context matters
and then impact
i often get like the concern well i
haven't
like influenced the lives of thousands
of people
that's okay
not everybody's gonna do that yet most
people will not do that right so
what does impact mean for you and that
is the most important definition i don't
i have no preference whether you've made
a deep impact with one person influenced
a small group maybe you did do something
on the global scale who knows right i
don't have a preference
but what does impact mean for you so a
couple of different ways for you to
explore that are
so what
i did something so what
but it also might feel a little
impersonal especially when it comes to
things with other people so another way
to ask yourself that is what's different
from my actions from my participation
for my presence there
what is different and that could be
another way for you to think about oh
that could be the impact or here are
some opportunities now that have opened
up right so lots of different ways to
think about impact leadership again i
said earlier comes through all paces in
your life
wherever it comes through we honor that
all right we're going quickly because i
do have a lot of content so i apologize
ahead of time if i'm speaking pretty
fast but now we're going to get into the
tactical practical
okay so how can i actually share these
things now that i have an idea of kind
of some of those milestones the
situations around them how do i actually
share that
so understand your tools
so
thinking about the activities interests
the parts of the application
for activities interest work history
these are kind of the four places that
i'm going to be focusing on today and
that's not to say that you can't be
talking about these things elsewhere in
your application but i really just want
to be able to focus on these chunks for
the moment
so
each section is going to ask you for a
particular type of information
we've been really careful and thoughtful
and just really intentional
even about the wording in any one of the
sections for each one of these um kind
of text boxes to ask information that's
going to be helpful for us and we do it
in a way that hopefully is also clear
what we're looking for
that said
how those pieces come together to tell
your story is going to be different and
i have examples
so you can use these sections either
individually or in dialogue with each
other right each section maybe you might
be a hat you might have different
answers for different situations for
different questions or you might be
answering one experience from multiple
directions so
the big takeaway here is give yourself
time to think
because if you just jump in and do one
section at a time
that's one of those missed opportunities
that i always
answer as like hey what's that biggest
mistake biggest opportunity
is actually to take a look at the tools
that you're working with
so
that means scan through it early open
that application now even if you're not
thinking about applying for a few years
or just
not really sure you want to apply right
check it out
here you don't need to read this
employment history instructions this is
actually a snapshot from the application
this is just to illustrate like we try
our best to be very um explicit about
the things that we're thinking about and
that what we want you to answer so
this will also if you take a look at it
early that can also help guide some of
your thinking so that you can create a
framework for oh here are things that i
want to add am i missing anything are
there other experiences so you don't
feel rushed at that 11th hour to be
adding kind of new pieces but rather
refining and kind of adding dimension to
what already exists
all right
here's where we get to some fun
everyone's journey is different and i
mentioned that earlier so everybody's
going to use their application to tell
stories differently so we're gonna do
some kind of
fun cases here um where if you were an
advisor or a friend
how would we support these two people so
i got two friends here so one is bill um
with one l um a zookeeper okay
next person is gil
also 1l
who is an entrepreneur loves has a
passion for kind of sustainability
grass astroturf you know part of that
landscaping consultancy
okay so we're approaching the
application how do we think about
especially the resume they're going to
be our friends for the resume examples
to really tell that story so we're going
to follow their journeys provide advice
and this is not to say this is how you
have to approach it
but here are some ways of thinking some
best practices that our friends
bill and gil
are going to help illustrate that
hopefully will be helpful as you move
through i fully recognize that some of
you might be really far along or might
have a lot of really great support
networks so this might seem a little um
maybe um foundational or basic for you
but take a moment and you know hopefully
you'll still find pieces that are going
to be helpful
so
and again this is in the context of the
mba application review process there
might be different advice different ways
you want to approach this because when
it comes to best practices and like that
format who is your audience
right
keep your audience in mind the thing
that
in the job industry in teaching
hiring managers might be looking for
different skill sets different
presentation than somebody who is
applying for an engineering role
same would go by extension if you're
applying to a business school what are
the things that that school is looking
for
stanford again past behavior as a key
indicator for how you might behave again
in the future
and it's not just the what but the how
and if you take those two pieces of
information together that can really
help inform the types of information you
put
in the application as a whole so keep
that audience in mind
one page basic business format right
there might be a few instances where you
go into the second page maybe you have
more than 10 years of work we definitely
have folks with decades of work
experience in our class so that will
never be an issue remember right at the
beginning it's not about how long you've
worked but what have you done given
that and everybody has a different kind
of path to the gsb we don't have a
preference at all for how many years of
work you have
and the third is optimize readability
you'd be surprised at how many
applications or resumes i see and it's
size 8 font
crammed all the way to the margins with
minimal space in between and it just
in
there's a tension right
how much space do i have versus how much
information do i want to communicate
and that is also reflective of some of
the challenges you're going to have as a
leader right how do you be succinct and
convey a message
how do you understand that audience so
already thinking about some of these
exercises as practice for future events
can also be a really useful way of using
this the application process also as a
growth opportunity
so we're going to give bill some advice
here uh
kind of approaching this brand new and i
also recognize that different countries
different industries have different
sensibilities about resumes and so
hopefully this will give you some
insights about the mba gsb i'm being one
of those so
photo not needed
a
you know you never know you you don't
want to put yourself up for pisces
whatever that might look like um also
that's landscape that you could be using
to tell me more information about
yourself i personally on the admission
side i do not care what you look like i
care about what you've done and how and
so this is one of those missed
opportunities that you could be using
the space to more um
kind of
to greater efficiency
objective
not necessary in the mba application
like side because in applying to the mba
like
i'm assuming that's your objective or
you're already talking about your other
goals in other parts of the application
so no need to put that there save that
space for something else
skill you know different waste
approaches there might be actual skills
that you want to include there
certification certainly qualify
or you know let's rethink a reframe
maybe you're embedding some of these
skills into the bullet points right so
there's different ways to communicate
kind of the talents and abilities that
you bring to the table
there's also a lot of white space here
and sometimes i see that happening
especially when people use columns or
different
kind of getting creative with a space
you do not need to be creative there's
no points for creativity again there's
no formula at all in our evaluation
process it's about conveying information
and in this open space negative space
can definitely be useful you don't want
it to be a complete block
but you also want to be thoughtful about
it and you know is this helping
my message or is it um kind of stopping
me from sharing something else and
that's going to be up to each one of you
as individuals
same thing as you look at this this
header lots of white space
um
again use it thoughtfully
because white space in that negative
space can also be a tool and so
think about kind of
silver lining of everything
all right so let's go on to content
so gil is a little bit further um has
some advice has a couple of mentors who
is shaping
who've helped advise on the resume
um so this is a generic template again
you do not have to follow this format it
works it works for gil
um
why
so
it allows you to to think okay what do i
want to put on there don't get into my
head as an admission officer
those questions earlier what is
important to you those are the things
that you should be putting in your
resume and think about the resume also
as a snapshot of who you are kind of
professionally educationally and
personally
you want to make sure that everything is
in your resume you might not need all
the details for everything because
there's parts in the application for you
to unpack those and explain those more
but
for the gsb process
your interviewer the only thing they
will see is an updated resume that you
share
and so if there's something that you
want to make sure that they see or is
that you might be able to refer to in a
conversation
you want to make sure it's there as well
as in the application where you might be
talking in a lot more detail right and
so make sure this is also an effective
snapshot of who you are
if it's important to you it's important
to us
here's something that i
have seen over time so this is not an
official like you must do this but be
thoughtful
some of the verbs that i see are very
general so
i led something or i launched something
i managed
what does that mean so take a moment and
think about some of those verbs that
you're using when you lead something
does that mean that you came up with the
idea and now that um and now you are
supervising
three people on its kind of inception
and execution
um
does it mean you actually literally led
people on a tour right so there's unpack
that what does that mean when you
launched something
uh was it a global launch was it um kind
of launching an idea among
um getting that idea off the ground with
senior leadership or was it actually
like rolling it out in markets
right so the more you're able to reflect
on some of those descriptors you might
not necessarily
use all those words in your resume or
your application but they'll help you
understand your your accomplishments and
your milestones
so that you can if you want to
or in an interview be able to talk about
it with that much more depth and
specificity
because those are the types of details
that are helpful for me in admissions
when i'm saying hey this is why bill or
this is why gil needs to come here here
is
what they accomplished and here's how
here are those leadership competencies
so
the more you're able to unpack and
articulate those for yourselves
it's actually doing me a service on the
admission side so thank you ahead of
time for doing the reflection
all right so for example okay now we
have bullet points what goes on those
bullet points
i'm gonna have two
ways of writing the same bullet point
again fictionalized um but which one
lands
which one has a bigger impact on you
so
founder sustainables turf consults
clients on landscape design and
opportunities for sustainability
or
landscape designs brought 22 clients
within city drought compliance standards
drought's a challenge climate change we
want to be thoughtful about that
four of those resulted in leed
certification
so
hopefully
the same one resonates for both of us
for me it's b
um and this
is a what do you do
versus what did you do
and there's actually going to be spaces
in the application itself in employment
history where it says give us a brief
description of your job
so
instead of having to do that here in the
resume you might still want to do that
depending on if it's a
unique or niche industry or job or role
or it's something that you want to
communicate to your um
whoever else might see it but you can
also use the space in your application
itself to do that if you want right
we're giving you that agency to make
that decision for yourself
but the bullet points hopefully are
gonna be a little bit more concrete what
did you do and here's where you know if
you're looking on the stuff that you did
it's easier to pin metrics to it what
are maybe some of those key performance
indicators
how did you stack up to those was this
overachieving going beyond or was this
something outside of your normal realm
of responsibilities
right
past behavior past context super helpful
in this process
all right so how technical should it be
this is another question i get a lot um
how new like because every industry has
its own set of jargon language
um keep your audience in mind so what do
i mean so gill
establishes hydroconscious
techno-natural xeriscapes utilizing
indigenous biota to facilitate
hydrosocial transformation in private
corporate and governmental spheres
cool so let's reframe rewrite and try
that again
uses native plants and landscapes best
practices
to assist private corporate and
government clients to develop water
conscious sustainability practices
a little easier i think maybe the second
pass more people might have understood
it
and if we looked at our past example of
what do you do versus what did you do
let's take it to that next step and now
translate that again to the 22 private
corporate government client
sustainability practice saving
and now you're able to put quantifiable
metrics there might actually be
additional pieces that you didn't
realize existed that i'm like oh wow
look at these accomplishments
part of this is the iterative process to
be able to put something down come back
to it and give yourself the time to
think through these it'll often be
helpful to have somebody to talk to
about it maybe it's someone who's
familiar with your work so can give you
some of that feedback
and maybe it's somebody who is outside
of your realm of work so they can tell
you i don't know what hydro conscious
techno natural xeriscapes are can you
break that down for me because while we
do have a lot of expertise in industries
and i can always ask folks on my team
with more experience in any given space
than i do for advice
you want to make it as easy as possible
for whoever's reading your application
or your resume for that matter
and i also left the little red squiggly
lines there on purpose because it does
two things
one it gets you to pay attention if your
word processor does not understand that
as a word
is that necessarily a word that you need
to do to convey what you did
is there another way for you to phrase
that that might be more understandable
to the general public
and the second is it caused your
attention because i spelled indigenous
wrong and so you also want to make sure
that you're approaching this
thoughtfully and um you know eyes
towards editing
misspelling something
that'll never hurt you in the process
but again this is a professional kind of
application process and you want to put
your best foot forward give yourself the
time again
to take a look at things
interpret does this convey who i am
effectively
will somebody else understand the things
that i've done and why they were
important
all right so a couple more resume facts
reframe and reclaim and then we're gonna
head over to the q a box i see a lot of
stuff in there that's gonna be helpful
so what if my work is confidential or i
sign a non-disclosure agreement so i
often get this question for folks who
work in government or defense
reframe that to what can i share to
provide appropriate insight into what
i've done or its impact
there's also the additional information
section so if you want to name it
do it and say i the work i do is
confidential i am not able to share kind
of the full extent of it but here is oh
right and that can also help give
contacts if your letters of recommend
your recommenders
also have kind of qualifications on what
they are able to say helps us context
matters
um
all of these tips
helpful regardless of what application
process you're using so this year we are
also using the consortium
and so
i'm looking at the same information
across all of the applications that come
in you'll notice if there is a
supplement
compare that to the main our own
application it's all the same questions
so there is no difference for me on this
end so all of the tips should be working
regardless of the process
um so same thing for this add that piece
of information because it could be
helpful
do i have to
format my resume in any type of way to
be effective
flip that
i have no preference i've seen some work
for different instances that maybe some
of the stuff i talked about today they
threw that those conventions out the
window when it worked ultimately i want
you to ask yourself what format will
help me convey my message most
effectively
sometimes is that second page necessary
there are times when you work for less
than 10 years or maybe it's helpful
if you remember uh in gil's uh resume
and maybe i can pop it up in a little
bit
there are a lot of publications right
citations take up space
i think if you have a publication you
should totally put in a citation
sometimes that gets you more into that
cv curriculum vitae world but
understanding things like um authorship
pub where was it published some of those
can be helpful pieces of information as
well and so
don't feel like you have to squeeze
everything into one page if you can
it's recommended but there are always
instances and always exceptions where oh
yeah you should totally go into that
second page so know that you also have
that agency to make that decision i will
never be like
two pages less than 10 years
but that is never going to be a thing
right i'm going to be looking through
because i'm going to say hey maybe there
is a reason why we're onto two pages or
hey maybe this is something that our
career management center can help coach
them on once they're here
okay
and so coming back to that resume 10
pages so i really need that second page
kind of got ahead of myself there
and if i can fit everything into the
resume what should i do
how can i make the rest of the
application work for me
and so we're going to come back to bill
because we focused on gil a lot with um
sustainable turf and
his resume so now let's talk about bill
bill's a zookeeper and so we're gonna
get that in the resume but
zookeeper there's a lot of potential
tasks is there a part of the zoo that
bill works in is there a particular
business development maybe it's actual
animal husbandry
maybe it's on the veterinary side
but maybe it's complex
hey in the employment history here's
that section i mentioned what are your
primary job responsibilities
that drop down for this job is was
full-time part-time internship so
nowhere that's pretty straightforward
reason for leaving maybe it's a
promotion maybe um
an opportunity showed up right there's
other things that um you might want to
be share with us
to help explain some of these
transitions you know that might not be
appropriate
or feasible in your resume think about
the employment history part on
application as a way to have dialogue
there and give us that information
so maybe bill launched a lemur
conservation program and there's an
award
you might see that award listed in the
resume but what like what was it for
what was the foundation of it in the
awards and awkward section you can tell
me a little bit more about that
what did you receive it for is it a
large scale thing is it a company
recognition give me some of that context
and maybe there's even more
maybe there's a so what of it maybe the
conservation program now has all allowed
for the um reintroduction of endangered
species back into their native habitat
in madagascar right what is that so what
maybe that's where you take that time to
provide some of that information the
context the challenges that so what
in the short optional answers that you
know in that bullet point in your resume
you might not have been able to cover
that in the honors awards maybe was
missing maybe doesn't fit elsewhere
the impetus for the short answer
questions actually came because
the what matters most to you and why
essay
hallmark of the jsb application
experience
um in the past we actually saw folks
putting in example like impact examples
of things that we're proud of that
didn't neatly flow with what matters
and we want you to be able to answer
in the spirit of the question
and so we decided to create these spaces
because if it was important to you it's
important to us we want to know about
your accomplishments why they're
important their impact so that's where
these optional short answer questions
got pulled out to give you the space to
do that so you can answer kind of in
fullness of what matters most to you in
the purity of that question so that's
where that came from
so hopefully that helps you see how
yes these parts of the application you
can use in dialogue with each other or
maybe for the short answer question it's
just something independent a little
standalone that might not have fit
neatly elsewhere
so being thoughtful move through the
application to see okay
how can i use this to best effect for
myself
and here's my last lie before i jump
into the q a box i do see a number of
questions there
think about it this way
in the spirit of reframe and reclaim
your experiences are your power
these are the things that i want to know
about you are the expert in you
your task is to figure out okay how can
i use this application and admissions
process including the interview or
whatever else might come along the way
to tell that story most effectively
each and every one of you has value
journalism or important understanding
who you are because of experiences is
important
right
so
really honor that and it can be hard at
first imposter syndrome those doubts
very real
and so this is also a process in
acknowledging that find folks who can
you can talk to about it maybe it's
talking to the admissions office maybe
you're emailing our main line and nancy
or maria is helping advise hey
think about it this way or
check out this website we have
information here that can help you right
or here's a webinar that we have already
check out this link that might be able
to support you right so think about the
different support networks to help you
identify and embrace that value
it takes time so thank you for joining
us this early in the summer as i
mentioned there's already other
videos available in case you want to get
a head start and start practicing some
of these things so you have time to
iterate and continue evolving over the
course until round one round two no
difference between applying round one or
round two um especially if you're
looking for um direct enrollment to
start next year
no preference and no difference on the
evaluation admission side whether you
apply through our platform or if we're
your u.s citizen
permanent resident through the
consortium or quest bridge if you're one
of uh clustered alumni
bottom line is
you are the most fascinating person in
the world to me when i'm reading your
application
you are the only thing that exists i
want to know about you this is a
confidential space for you to tell me
whatever it is you want about you i'm
not sharing this information with
faculty members no students will see
this as i mentioned earlier your
interviewers will only see your an
updated resume that you share with them
and so please know that i am honoring
the space
because i know for some folks you might
be going into vulnerable spaces um
sometimes even sharing the things you
care about and are excited about can be
um
can have feelings attach them this is a
space where we honor that
thank you for letting me share in your
journey but right now i'm going to go
ahead and jump into the q a box
um to see where i can
do help out with these last few minutes
we have together
so lenica how to telling your story and
communicating your background to
stanford um
change in the different um spaces that
you might be applying via there's no
difference so
there's no additional lens or
perspective as i mentioned i'm going to
be looking
we're asking for the same types of
information across whatever platform
you're applying to the gsb through
we talk about equity and this is an
exercise in that and so for us so for
you
what this means is
you don't have to change anything about
your approach share you
in any one of those spaces what i will
recommend is for each of the schools
that you might be applying through
through the consortium check with them
if there's ways that they recommend
approaching their parts of the
supplement or their own institutional
supplements and that could be a way to
help make sure that you are honoring the
process that every school has put in
place
um do i recommend tying together
experiences from different industries
from hannah up to you um and because for
some people they might be different
chapters for others there might be a
continuation of different themes
maybe you're connecting those in an
essay somewhere and not in kind of the
optional places or your employment
history necessarily maybe it's
even opportunities in different
industries that you've experienced
during college who are you because of
those right reclaim that power
who are you and i think that is
in a very very weird way an incredible
lens to look at a professional um
trajectory um that'll actually be really
nice to think about like
unpacking that sense of self-awareness
because thinking about who's some of the
most successful and
kind of effective leaders that sense of
self-awareness
can be really really helpful there um
okay
professional experience on the direct
enrollment should only be post-grad work
internships held during college are to
go in the activities and intersections
similarly on the resume should college
internships go under activities and
interests rather than work experience
good question brandon
that's up to you
so i have no preference where that goes
um if anything i i've seen it go
anywhere oftentimes for internships
they'll say as your title intern or what
role you had and that'll be clear enough
of a demarcation for me i know some
people will say professional experience
kind of broadly other folks might
separate it into full-time employment
versus internships because they might
have had multiple
again make this space work for you what
makes the most sense for you
uh three-year entrepreneurial work on
the resume is it too much of a two-page
cv from brian it depends
and
take a look what is it that you're
trying to communicate what's helpful
here and in the gsb application process
it's not to the just just the
descriptions
of what you do remember but what did you
do why was it important
go ahead and take a look at the other
parts of your application where hey
maybe i'm just listing some of these
things here
as maybe like a list bullet points
whatever and then the application i'm
unpacking them to give more of that
detail so again think creatively across
the different spaces do you need that
two page
if yes do it if not where else can i
share that information
um how do i justify job five job changes
in 10 10 years of work experience
let us know you don't need to justify we
know every
career trajectory is different if you
want to explain additional information
you can even go in there if you're not
already telling me a little about about
it to the rest of your application
additional information you can say here
are some of the circumstances um where
that have informed why i've moved across
multiple jobs you'd be surprised at how
common that is and so
don't feel like you're at a disadvantage
necessarily
think about given those peop experiences
what have you done who are you because
of them how have you kind of managed the
spaces that you've been in
so once again thank you so much for
joining me today hopefully there was a
couple pieces of information here that
were helpful
end of the day
you got this
take care hopefully i'll be able to
interact with you again over the course
of the summer but once again every
journey is valuable
you are awesome and if nobody has told
you yet today i hope that today gives
you something to smile about
take care all
you